cette machine ne remonte qu'à trois semaines,
mais il y a encore des choses que nous pouvons bien changer,
je viens d'échouer dans mon rapport Chem et je
ne veux pas vraiment répéter l'
expérience de 12e année quatre appâts et changer d'
accord, tout le monde s'installe,
allez oiseau, finissons-en avec
danse Lou hydrogène hélium lithium
béryllium bore carbone azote oxygène
fluor néon un moyen de fluorer le
poids atomique le sauriez-vous ou pas
ouais c'est la dernière fois alors pourquoi
saurais-je que c'est la dernière fois de quoi
diable parlez-vous
Gus Newton Tommy pourquoi  s'il lui demandait
qu'il pense que je vais le jour de la marmotte
prêt
tout le monde s'installe Goldberg
alors en finir avec l'hydrogène hélium
lithium béryllium bore carbone azote
oxygène fluor néon sodium quel est le
poids atomique du sodium 22,98 quelle est
la classification du silicium classification des télécommunications
est semi-métallique et sa
configuration électronique est un e3 su
et son numéro atomique est 14 Oh Lou, ça
vient de vous arriver